This video was made possible by Brilliant.
Learn with Brilliant for 20% off by being
one of the first 200 to sign up at brilliant.org/Wendover.
A single aircraft carrier is enough to markedly
change the level of a nation’s military
might.
These ships are one of the strongest single
assets a military can have.
In general, under international law, aircraft
carriers can legally position themselves up
to 14 miles or 22 kilometers from any country’s
coast.
Clearly, the strategic influence of being
able to place a military airbase just miles
from any coast in the world is enormous especially
given that 80% of the world’s population
lives within 60 miles or 100 kilometers from
the ocean.
While plenty of military vessels are capable
of launching helicopters, there are just 19
aircraft carriers worldwide currently in service
capable of launching fixed-wing airplanes.
China, Thailand, India, Russia, and France
each have one; Italy has two; and the US has
the eleven largest in the world.
These largest carriers require over 6,000
people to operate and often stay deployed
for up to a year.
They are fully fledged cities at sea.
The most advanced aircraft carriers like the
French Navy’s Charles de Gaulle are capable
of launching an aircraft every 30 seconds.
That means that, for a brief period, when
launching aircraft at its maximum rate, the
aircraft carrier Charles de Gaulle becomes
busier than Charles de Gaulle Airport in Paris.
To be able to achieve such a capability on
a moving ship is no easy feat.
While the operation of these vessels gives
militaries enormous strategic advantage, they
also represent one of their greatest operational
challenges.
An aircraft carrier’s offensive weapon is
its aircraft.
Onboard, carriers tend to only have a small
number of defensive weapons such as surface-to-air
missiles and machine guns.
But of course, just like any powerful military
asset, these carriers are big targets.
It is for this reason that carriers never
travel alone while on deployment.
While the exact composition can change depending
on the mission, the carrier strike groups
American carriers travel with are typically
made up of a guided missile cruiser equipped
with tomahawk missiles, two guided missile
destroyers, an attack submarine, and a supply
ship.
An aircraft carrier is the flagship of this
strike group meaning that, in it’s command
area, it not only has a bridge and air traffic
control center, it also has a flag bridge
where an admiral commands the entire strike
group.
Each of the group’s ships serve some combination
of offensive and defensive roles.
The only exception is the supply ship.
Most aircraft carriers don’t need regular
refueling.
All eleven American carriers and the French
one are nuclear powered meaning they can sail
an unlimited distance for twenty-five years
without refueling.
Even conventionally powered aircraft carriers
like the UK’s HMS Queen Elizabeth can travel
up to 12,000 miles or 18,000 kilometers without
refueling making the need for stops infrequent.
While an American or French carrier could
hypothetically sail nonstop for years or even
decades, what they can’t do is carry enough
food, which is always needed, and aviation
fuel, which is needed for combat operations,
to stay at sea for more than a few weeks at
a time.
It would be inefficient and place the carriers
in a position of vulnerability to have to
visit a port every few weeks to restock especially
during combat operations so they don’t—they
restock while at sea.
The supply ships that move as part of the
strike group will sail off to a nearby port
to take on fuel, ammunition, food, and mail,
sail back to the strike group, then match
speed and maneuver alongside the carrier.
From there the two ships will shoot lines
across to each other.
These lines are used to pull hoses over to
the carrier which are used to transfer aviation
fuel.
To transfer solid supplies, there are two
methods.
The first is attaching pallets to dollies
that wheel cargo across to the carrier like
a zipline.
The second method, which is considered simpler
yet more dangerous, is using helicopters to
pick up pallets from the resupply ship and
flying them over to the carrier.
These transfers bring both crucial supplies
like food and some less crucial items like
mail but this isn’t the only way mail arrives
on American aircraft carriers.
Each carrier actually has a mailing address
just like any building in the US.
For example, this is the USS Gerald R. Ford’s
address.
Families of sailors can send mail to these
addresses in the same way that they would
to to any other and, in fact, it costs the
exact same as a shipment to any other US address—even
if the ship is on the other side of the world.
Sailors can even order packages online to
their ship.
Expedited mail often makes it from an address
in the US to a carrier sailing somewhere around
the world in just ten days.
Having this speed requires more frequent deliveries
than those of the logistics ships but conveniently,
carriers are airports at sea.
American carriers currently use a fleet of
C-2 Greyhound’s as cargo aircraft providing
a high-frequency, often daily connection between
carriers and shore.
When cruising in the South China Sea, for
example, as the USS Ronald Reagan did in November,
2018, mail might be sent to Singapore via
conventional means.
A C-2 Greyhound would then fly from the ship
to Singapore, pick up the mail, and fly back
to the ship.
As carriers sail around the world, the pick-up
points of the C-2 Greyhounds are continuously
shifted to nearby friendly nations.
While mail does wonders for increasing crew
morale, that’s actually the lowest priority
cargo for the C-2 Greyhounds.
The aircraft are integral for bringing on
spare parts for all the carrier’s aircraft
and transporting VIP’s, press, and other
individuals to and from the carriers.
This C-2 Greyhound is about the same size
as an Embraer 145—a civilian aircraft capable
of carrying 50 people—so it’s not tiny.
The longest aircraft carrier in the world,
which also happens to be the newest, is the
USS Gerald R. Ford but even she is only 1,106
feet or 337 meters long.
With commercial airports, a runway of 5,000
feet or 1,500 meters, like the one at London
City Airport in London, is considered short
while large airports like London Heathrow
will have runaways longer than 10,000 feet
or 3,000 meters.
So how do C-2 Greyhounds and other aircraft
on carriers deal with having runways of only
1,100 feet or 330 meters long?
They don’t.
They take off with just 325 feet or 99 meters
of space.
All US and French carriers use a system of
catapults to get aircraft up to takeoff speed
within three to four seconds.
This allows these carriers to launch decently
sized aircraft, like the C-2 Greyhound, with
their relatively short decks.
Other carriers, like the Chinese and Indian
ones, don’t have catapults so they can only
launch lighter, shorter range aircraft capable
of taking off with a very short runway.
Both these two types of carriers have arrestor
wires that aircraft catch on landing to decelerate
with the short distance given.
Every other aircraft carrier out there can
only operate with aircraft capable of vertical
landing.
What takes place on the flight deck is carefully
choreographed chaos.
On American carriers, everyone’s job is
easily identifiable by the color shirt they
wear.
Yellow shirts deal with navigating aircraft
around the deck.
Blue shirts are assistants to yellow shirts
driving tugs, operating elevators, delivering
messages, and more.
Red shirts do all the handling and mounting
of ammunition.
Purple shirts manage aircraft fueling.
Green shirts are worn by a few different groups
including catapult crews, maintenance personnel,
cargo handlers, and more.
White shirts are also worn by a mix of personnel
including those helping aircraft land, working
as medical personnel, and more.
And lastly, brown shirts are worn by plane
captains who are not those that fly the aircraft—they’re
individually in charge of overseeing all work
for getting an aircraft ready for flight.
The flight deck is a dangerous place given
its small size.
It’s so small that all the carrier’s aircraft
can’t fit on it but of course just below
the flight deck is the hangar.
A large carrier can carry up to 100 aircraft
so massive elevators bring aircraft from the
flight deck to the hangar for storage when
not in use.
About 6,000 people work and live aboard each
American carrier.
3,200 of them have jobs relating to running
the ship itself.
That includes everything from working in the
engine room, maintaining the nuclear reactor,
cleaning the decks, to actually working up
in the bridge commanding the ship.
Many of these jobs are below deck and, since
all the above deck space is used for flight
operations, many onboard can go weeks without
seeing sunlight.
2,500 other personnel are part of the carrier’s
air wing.
If this was an airbase on land, these would
be everyone working there including air traffic
controllers, aircraft mechanics, fuelers,
pilots, and more.
The few hundred remaining personnel work assorted
other jobs.
In terms of personal space, enlisted personnel,
the vast majority of those onboard, only get
a single bunk in a room with sometimes more
than a hundred others.
Higher ranked individuals, though, of course
have more spacious accommodations.
As long-term homes for thousands of people,
these ships also have a few small luxuries
like stores, gyms, barber shops, lounges and
more but space is at a premium when 6,000
people are packed into one floating hull and
the mission is paramount.
Since their heyday in World War Two, some
have started to question the place aircraft
carriers have in modern warfare.
Every operating country aside from the US
tend to, at any given moment, have their ships
either in combat, in training, or at home.
The US tends to use its carriers for a forth
function—power projection.
At any given moment, there is almost certainly
an American carrier cruising somewhere in
the world.
In fact, January 2017 was the first time since
World War Two that there was not an American
aircraft carrier on deployment.
Even if there wasn’t an aircraft carrier
on deployment, they’re fast.
They have a top speed of 35 miles or 56 kilometers
per hour meaning that a Norfolk, Virginia
based carrier could get to the Middle East
in just a week.
In the Pacific, the US has an even greater
advantage since it has the USS Ronald Reagan
based in Yokosuka, Japan from where it could
reach the shores of North Korea, for example,
in just 29 hours.
American carriers spend plenty of time just
cruising around the world’s oceans reminding
other country’s of the US military’s power.
For example, the USS Ronald Reagan returned
from a four-month deployment from August to
December 2018 during which it saw zero combat.
It spent much of the time cruising around
the South China Sea—an area in which China
is attempting to assert military control much
to the US’ displeasure.
Elsewhere in Asia, American carriers also
regularly make visits to the Korean peninsula
to remind North Korea of their presence.
This reached a peak in November 2017 as tensions
with North Korea reached a peak when three
American carriers loomed near the Korean shores.
With their enormous power, though, aircraft
carriers represent an enormous target especially
in the era of stealthy drones and precise
missiles.
The sinking of a single US aircraft carrier
could result in more American military deaths
than the entire Iraq war in addition to the
loss of tens of billions of dollars in military
assets.
While no aircraft carrier of any nation has
been sunk since World War Two, it’s potentially
more possible than one would think.
US carriers regularly participate in war games
where combat conditions are simulated with
allies.
There have been two concerning incidents in
2005 and 2015 where Swedish and French submarines,
respectively, have “won” the games against
US carriers.
What this means is that the two country’s
submarines approached close enough to the
carriers where they could have, if they were
an enemy in real combat, launched torpedoes
and potentially sank the carriers.
This, in essence, proves that aircraft carriers,
with all their defense, are not as unsinkable
as some may say.
Meanwhile, the US has already received the
first of ten in a new class of carriers while
China, India, and the UK each have carriers
under construction so, despite their possible
obsolescence, we can be sure that the aircraft
carrier won’t be leaving the world’s oceans
anytime soon.
I have a logic question for you.
Suppose there are two doors and the first
has a sign on it saying, “If this door is
safe, the other door is deadly.”
If that sign is false, what do you know about
the doors?
Which are deadly and which are safe?
Take a moment to think about it and, if you
figure out the answer, leave it in the comments.
This is a question from brilliant.org's logic
quiz which teaches you analytical skills through
logical puzzles.
That’s just one of many superbly designed
courses on Brilliant through which you can
learn about dozens of topics including group
theory, multivariable calculus, statistics,
number theory, machine learning, and more.
They’re experts on teaching scary, complicated
subjects in a way in which you can actually
understand them by breaking them down into
their fundamental principles.
Get started learning with Brilliant for free
at brilliant.org/Wendover and then, the first
200 people that go to that link will get 20%
off their annual premium subscription.